in the far corner of the known world the
lights are fading it is the end of the
fifth century the beginning of the Dark
Ages
on the island of the Britain's strife
and chaos are growing civilization is on
the verge of collapse for centuries the
Britons have enjoyed the peace and
prosperity that comes with their status
as citizens of Rome
but the Empire is crumbling and the
Romans are pulling out
the Britons are on their own barbarians
flood into the country wreaking havoc
with their world falling apart
where people need a hero
and according to the story they get one
enter Arthur king of the Britons like a
Dark Age Superman he sweeps through the
land his legend growing with each act of
bravery and daring do
the Britons have found their leader
Arthur is a dashing King adored by the
people feared by his enemies he rides
into battle under a menacing dragon
banner wielding the legendary blade
Excalibur given to him by the Lady of
the lake to replace the sword he pulled
from the stone he is aided by an
all-powerful sorcerer
the great wizard Merlin who helps him
rule the land from the legendary Castle
Camelot
at his side stands his loving wife
Guinevere a fifth-century blonde
bombshell
around him the best nights of the land
Sir Gawain
the brave Sir Galahad the pure Sir
Lancelot the handsome
Arthur welds them together with a
revolutionary code of chivalry
represented by the round table
together they drive out the evil
invaders and defend the land from the
devious sorceress Morgana
then it's off on the ultimate quest for
God and glory in search of the Holy
Grail
things it seems couldn't be better in
the blessed Kingdom Britain is saved
King Arthur's tale is one of the
greatest legends of all time it has
captivated countless generations with
its thrilling adventure magic and
romance but the King Arthur fan club
dates back to the dark ages yeah
building a bear strong god bless the
king yet if it sounds a little too good
to be true that's probably because it is
yeah well actually I never saw him
the fact is 1,500 years later historians
are still trying to determine if the
legendary King was real